i don't know if van pelt's on hold i
want him to understand he's not the only
guy who gets the stars in the game
just kidding
[Laughter]
is he on hold for real
hello scott van pelt you there
yeah i mean i just got done hosting a
show for two hours i'm sorry that i
wasn't there the second you needed me
oh my gosh still my word no i'm i'm i'm
i wasn't doing that i hope you're okay
is everything all right
are we good no i'm just kidding i'm i'm
shoving a cheese cracker in my face i
was trying to pick up
and um for some reason my phone was
screwing up but here i am thrilled
to be here as always how are you sir i
am doing great how is everything in
augusta
how's everything there brother what does
it look like um
it's weird odd yeah yes odd but still
familiar if that makes any sense like
it's
like for if you celeb if you said hey
we're gonna do christmas and we're going
to do it in july you go
okay and then you busted out the tree
and the decorations and your wrap
presents and you came down and it was 90
outside
and you were opening presents in july
you'd think well okay the trees familiar
the presence this is all
wonderful i'm happy to celebrate this
it's just odd because it's not when
we typically would do this so it's
strange not having
uh not having the patrons as they're
referred to here at augusta national
is really jarring they are such a huge
part of the soul of the place
and the players have all commented it's
just so strange
and it will be stranger once the once
the event begins
but just everything else is incredibly
familiar it's immaculate like it always
is it's a huge
event you guys are obviously they're
gonna do everything that they can to win
it
and what does it look like with turning
leaves what does that look like
scott it must look incredible it's
they're it's not as if they're
there there aren't as as uh they haven't
changed as much
as say you know new england which i know
was a long time ago but you remember
fall in new england or where i am now in
dc where
the colors have clearly kind of come and
gone it's not quite like that there's
some trees that have changed
but i mean it's still awfully green and
i mean as i stand here and look at the
practice range it's more green than it
is anything else
that's i'm just excited and i guess
why did they choose middle of november
did they did they
want to make sure that the course was
closed for a while or what what
what was it what is it part of it i mean
i think i think at the time in in the
spring the hope was that we'd be out of
where we were in in terms of cobit and
actually you know now enemy obviously
we're testing more in this map but i
mean it's
it's not it's not any better uh but i
think what it gave the golf course a
chance to do is go through the summer
and um and the fall to get it prepared
to compete it'll be different in terms
of
how it plays it'll play longer and then
it's going to rain a ton on thursday so
that's going to make it an issue
but this was this gave them the best
chance to have the golf course
as they would have wished it to be to
present the event
scott van pelt here on the rich eisen
show fresh off of the set
uh of coverage uh for espn at uh augusta
national right here on the rich eisen
show we spoke to our buddy tarico
on monday and he said it's it's it's
bryce and deshambo's week
to be talked about and and that by the
end of the week that's all we're going
to be talking about would you um
would you agree with that assessment no
okay no be because
i he here's here's he'll he's going to
hit it a mile
we know that and i might look foolish
saying that now but i'll say it because
this place
you can hit as far as you want great
you're going to have you're going to
have shorter clubs into
these greens again great he's got to put
the ball better here
or he will not win and the last three
years statistically is strokes gain
putting he's dead
last and andy made the poor point on the
show that i found really interesting
that he's a guy who leans on his
his putting books in the in the which
kind of are the
they're basically the the template each
week on the pga tour of what the greens
are they don't have those here
and he's a guy that is really really has
a
fascinating mind and uses all of this
all the intel and feedback
much the way front offices use analytics
and here it's going to have to be more
feel and less information
and so i think maybe that's part of why
he hasn't put it particularly well
but also you're allowed to get better
you know there's nothing to say that he
won't putt better this week
my my only counter to mike would be
unless he puts better he won't win
if he does putt well then he might win
on a walk the way he did it at wingfoot
but
i mean he's going to hit the ball places
out here if it
if it drives out any that people just
won't believe
because it's i mean it's absurd some of
the things that we're talking about like
driving it over the trees on 13 and
hitting the wedge in like that's his
play on the par 5
yeah i mean i asked mike if if there's
anyone that he could any any holes that
he could table par four he mentioned the
third and that's about
it but i mean we're we're gonna just see
watch him jack nicklaus rich jack
nicklaus said
that on the in the right win conditions
that he could drive one
i mean i i stood on one t yesterday and
i contemplated that and then i walked
away
i mean it makes no bleeping sense man um
it's i can't even fathom that that's
possible but
i mean jack i defer to jack when it
comes to nationals yeah suggested that
it won't happen this week because it'll
be too wet but i mean just the fact that
we're talking about
that but and i don't want to get too
golfy here but i mean
the chairman fred ridley said today that
we're getting uh close to a call to arms
about
about how far the golf ball is going my
guess is that very soon here
you'll see the ruling bodies do
something to limit how far golf ball
goes
because if they don't then you're going
to run out of real estate for these
courses to
to be played on yeah i mean that's
that's the question um
and just like just to go down the
checklist of what i talked about with
with uh with mike uh do we come up with
a new phrase right now about
uh if deshambo does hit it a ton and
tear it up
is it uh uh brysonizing the course or
what's the one that trijo came up to
shambies do you deshambize
uh augusta nationals you can't you keep
there
there's only someone listen augusta
national has they don't
they don't like the term money so
indeference they they have resources
rich and the resources they have are
unlimited
to acquire land around the golf course
but there's only so big you can make
this place
and there's nothing you can do sure
unless
unless the greens are your defense and
they have been the defense against him
thus far but
in terms of making it long enough we're
gonna make it nine thousand yards and
no you can't scott van pelt here on the
rich eisen show who are we not talking
about who should we be talking about
this week what do you think uh zander
schofley
um zander is the guy that andy just
picked him on the show i picked him
before i got here i mean he's finished
in the top
10 more than half of the last majors in
the last three years i mean he's he's
finished second last year um you know
he's going to win majors plural i i'm
convinced of that
um and so at some point it begins
i it's just now's as good a time as any
but the thing about this course
rich as you know is that there are there
are so many players who show up
and think oh yeah like dustin johnson i
play well there john rahm hasn't played
here a lot he plays well here justin
rose i
lost in a playoff there and then they're
all the guys that have won it that show
up and think i can compete
so and justin thomas hasn't won it yet
he's getting better every year there's
there's so many people rich that come
here and you and and if they won you'd
go sure of course
and there are so many guys that you
think will eventually win and then some
of them like ernie ells and
greg norman and tom weiskopf and david
duvall never do
so like it's it's it's a place everyone
loves
and who's the guy lucky enough to be the
guy that plays the best i mean that
that's
that's the thing i if i knew on
wednesday i'd meet you in vegas and we'd
never work a day again
yes indeed so you like xander schofley
out of the top 10 players coming in
uh you'd like i do you like xander okay
um
let's just say let's just say that if
you
take a second tier of players from
ranking in the world uh
between 11 and 20. um
and you had that list in front of you
because i might have texted you about
that earlier
who would you take in that and i might
have done that homework and i might have
put that list together already
[Laughter]
all right um and this is just for me to
utilize
uh let's just say okay because if you're
because if you're picking against other
people they won't pick him and they
should he plays well here he played well
the last event he played
i like matsuyama from those 11 through
20. okay
and let's just say uh my buddy chris
brockman decided to put something
together where there's a third tier of
players
as well yeah uh between 21 and 32. who
would you choose uh from that uh
give you a guy no one will have from
that list because there are a lot of
people that you could pick but take
coke crack at 20. who just won in vegas
and hits the ball a
mile again i'm trying to give you some
people i don't think others would select
because they're not as smart as me
jason kokrak by the way if if killing
will have that person no one else will i
appreciate that if kilbourne was doing
still doing sportscenter it'd be jason
krokrakatella
right that's that's there you go i think
uh all right uh tier four let's just see
let's just keep going down all the tiers
uh between 34 and 45.
um who do you think's going to be the
next three without stopping
your next tier i want you to take a dog
kevin kisner you got to put it around
here kisner puts it well and
and obviously like everyone else loves
it he's played here like 60 times
kisner in your 40s here jason day i
can't believe is available still this is
like when you draft in your fantasy trap
and someone's still there yeah gay is in
the 50s a major champion way too good to
be
ranked at that space and still get them
and then again
no one's gonna have my main man lanto
he competed well at the pg again i'm
just i'm trying to give you
because if we're doing like drafts and
everyone's going to have some version of
the same thing but if you
if you have matsuyama ko crack kisner
atlanta you'll be
standing by yourself and it might be
worthless like by by
thursday night it might absolutely be
worthless but uh that's who i scribbled
down that's why i scribbled down richard
lanto calrissian griffin there you go
all right espn plus save me and booger
oh man how is life in dc i know you
wanted to move there to be closer to
family scott and it was remarkable that
uh espn said go for it and they built
your beautiful set and your show is just
as great as ever
how's that working for you thank you uh
it's you know it's it's good it's you
as having kids and and and dealing with
moving and trying to get them adjusted
in the world of
that we're in and not things aren't as
easy to meet people it's
i it's challenging more so than i
thought it might be but i'm home i'm
close to family mom
you know is able to come by anytime she
wants which you know is
is what it's about and um we're in the
same studio as tony and mike have done
pti for years and
uh where ted koppel used to host
nightline don't tell me that i thought
they should not let me walk in the same
place that that man worked and
and so it's it's all surreal uh driving
down familiar streets in dc and
and that's where i am it's it's it's all
hard to fathom but i'm just grateful you
know i'm grateful we get to do what we
do and
and grateful to be able to be home to do
it and you've got uh the uh
i don't want to say the other tango
viloa but uh the second one
uh crushing it for your alma mater right
now scott that's going to be happening
i mean they you know look i mean i they
were 20-point dogs to minnesota they
beat him they were 20 some point dogs to
penn state they beat him i mean
i don't think that maryland is beating
ohio state uh but
nevertheless it's a couple of wins for
to his brother who's pretty good
almost happened last year scott i'm just
happy hey look anything that gets played
right now rich
i'm celebrating you know i'm just i'm
hoping the nfl can hang on here
i keep trudging along because they've
done as great a job as they can trying
to handle it all well scott i know again
that you've been uh working like crazy i
appreciate you just popping on the phone
and uh
enjoy augusta enjoy that and enjoy going
home to your family and uh let's
let's chat around the holidays i'd love
it if you don't mind i look forward to
that be well i hope this list isn't
totally useless
um but i i did i actually put thought
into it even though it might appear i
didn't
no trust me when uh it's the first
we're thrilled that we've been here six
years and uh now that we've got a new
home in peacock i think it's the first
time
we've ever heard the name lanto griffin
let alone streamed it
um you know simulcast so i appreciate it
i'm i'm thrilled to have made history
with you here scott you can just join
the pool if you want it's not no no no
no no no no no no he's not gonna do
something like that this man's uh this
man
this man uh i i he doesn't want to take
a bad beat in this one either
okay so wow that's true hey look al
michael's referenced this side it's a
good work that's
worldwide baby worldwide
take care of yourself scott enjoy the
week enjoy it brother be well you got it
that's
the family same to you that scott van
pelt one of my favorites
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here